CSS also supports background images and
this feature can be used to achieve a
number of responsive effects you can use
CSS to add a background pattern to an
element or the page itself and you can
combine that with gradients and other
CSS effects it's possible to get some
incredible effects with pure CSS check
out the examples on the website link to
below the video with the background size
cover property CSS can also be used to
add a background image that resizes
without squashing or stretching and
again this can be really handy for using
images when you don't know the size of
the viewport the details in a photo can
get lost when it's shrunk so this
example displays the whole image of the
viewport is more than 500 pixels wide or
a smaller crop otherwise I've added a
CSS transition so there's not too much
of a job if you resize the window you'll
see that the devtools the smaller koala
crop is displayed downloaded when the
window is small and then you resize the
window larger the larger crop is
downloaded and displayed CSS background
images can be used for conditional
display of images depending on viewport
size using CSS like this as you can see
from the devtools the background image
file is not downloaded if the viewport
width is less than 500 pixels now you'll
find out more about media queries later
and a much less hacky and a much more
efficient way to accomplish alternative
image loading when we look at the source
set attribute and the picture element in
lesson 3 with background images you can
also use the CSS image set function to
choose a background image depending on
screen resolution this example displays
a 2 X color image on a high resolution
display like my phone and a 1x
monochrome image otherwise for devices
that don't support image set the CSS
falls back to the 1x version if you
check the dev tools you'll see that only
the appropriate image is downloaded
you'll learn a lot
or about responding to screen resolution
in lesson three